Bruce Feldman joining us here from Fox
Sports si.com
what was yesterday all about Bruce for
those who might not be familiar well
rich I think a lot more top recruit
signed this week and are signing this
week and this early sign of her than
anybody really would have anticipated oh
you know when this thing was first
created
you know everybody I talked to her
coaches were saying you know what we
expect in the last week 75% of our
classes on well you looked at it nine of
the top ten recruits in the country in
the class of 2018 they signed yesterday
I think it's gonna be by the end of
tomorrow it'll be at least 24 of the top
30
so all that drama that people you
normally expect on the first Wednesday
in February a quote-unquote signing day
that's gonna be diffused a lot and there
was way less of a TV presence I mean
ESPN which used to have so much high
wattage devoted towards signing day you
know it was on the SEC network it was on
the Big Ten Network it was a little
ESPNU but it was it was very low-key on
that front and I think so you had less
drama and the big winners were Georgia
Kirby Smart is cleaning up I mean six
five-star guys the top quarterback
recruit in the country Justin fields
which is pretty remarkable you consider
that they had the All SEC Freshman who
led him into the playoff Jake Robb and
now they have a quarterback who a lot of
people think is much more talented in
the last two years when they've had five
star quarterbacks come in so you know
hats off to Georgia hats off to Clemson
and and I think we're seeing a lot of
people still try to figure out how do we
do this juggling act between getting our
teams ready for the bowl sign and also
you have a lot of coaching shake-up with
assistance that's gonna start happening
right now so why did it why did this
take place why why why did this happen
there's been a real push for a while
rich from coaches saying you know what
let's try to do something for these
recruits who feel like they're just
getting hounded they made their decision
up in you know some of them in the
spring of their junior year they know
where they want to go let's get it out
of the way so we don't have to keep
recruiting these kids
for you know and added two months now I
think what some of the smaller schools
have said is hey we'd love that because
then you know we our kids don't get
poached you know we're on to them we're
the ones who stick our necks out we
offer them early we do all the
recruiting and all of a sudden you know
these bigger schools in the last month
and a half after their seasons are done
they look in and they have they have
they're at the top of the food chain and
they can swoop in and get some of these
kids I mean and what you saw and this
there's a probably good example of this
yesterday there was an offensive lineman
from walk from the state of Washington
had been committed to Washington State
for a while
us he tried to come in on him late and
that kid was like no I'm already set for
and signed with with Washington State I
think if this is the normal process
where he has to wait until early
February that kid might be a USC Trojan
I think we examples of that are
happening more and more this year
Bruce Feldman of Fox Sports si.com
joining me here so is this a good thing
you think it's a good thing I think
there's some good elements here's the
downside to it and I'm not a la not many
people have brought this up this is why
I was skeptical of an ollie sign if
you're going through the academic
picture for these kids meaning you don't
have even a first full semester grades
come in test scores for their senior
year you're gonna have a lot of kids who
schools are going to roll the dice on
and they're gonna sign and they're
probably not going to qualify and what
it's also doing is this recruiting
calendar keeps moving up earlier and
earlier I mean serious it's not uncommon
now to see to see sophomores and
freshmen in high school getting offers
now you can't sign that right away but I
just think you know people are going to
be moving earlier and earlier they're
gonna know it less and less about the
academics you can have a lot of bad
decisions that are going to be made in
the wake of it I'm not sure what's going
to happen as some of those kids who end
up getting squeezed and that did they go
to junior college that you know I don't
know if that's necessarily a good thing
because these coaches can't help
themselves they're just so competitive
with each other they don't do anything
in moderation so tell me about the
foreign market I saw your tweets about
that including
some freakish defensive end that signed
with the Wolverines Bruce yeah yes well
shop is his name he is from Bavaria he
grew up as a champion mogul skier you
know the guy
there's an old defensive lineman who
played in the CFL and brief Landy and
they in the NFL who played for Don brown
the Michigan defensive coordinator back
when at UMass and he is set up in in
Germany and he has really tried to have
these camps and combines two he says you
know what I got about fifty to a hundred
you know legit division one football
players just walking around Europe who
are really athletic kids who deserve a
shot
he brought 15 of them last year on a on
a tour of camps julius he said and you
know he said when this kid reached out
to him six six to 45 he could run a four
or five didn't believe it the kid drove
six hours to him and in like in a minute
like a snowstorm and he brought jump ten
five and he said he ran four or five you
know and changed now when I talked to
some school that had him in camp they
said alright he's a really great athlete
he ran for eight he buddy broad jump ten
feet and for a kid who's six six to
forty plus that's pretty amazing and so
I think Michigan has got them so they
really really impressive physical
specimen we'll see what he becomes in a
couple of years once he gets really good
really good coaching well during that
explanation use gave me I just looked up
on Google how to say go blue and German
so Gabe Wow I'll get me in some what it
looks like right now video this kids you
on a tightrope between two trees on a
balance beam where he's like I mean it's
a huge tight end sized guy doing this
where he's bending the rope and he's
making it all the way across I mean he's
doing stuff that you're just not usually
seeing at American high school video
football I hear ya does that translate
to winning in the horseshoe next
November Bruce that's what a lot so
that's kind they translate three years
from now but if you're gonna take a
chance take a chance on a big athletic
guy so a couple more minutes with Bruce
Feldman here on the on the Rich Eisen
show Josh Rosen still in a concussion
protocol
and I'm wondering is part of that we've
seen we've seen somebody you might not
want to play in a bowl game where does
that all stand from last year when for
net McCaffrey started making headlines
around this time of year last year Bruce
you know I what I've been told he they
will probably make a decision right
the day before maybe on that with the
doctors and whatever the doctors say I
was under the impression that that Josh
Rosen was gonna follow that if he's
cleared you know he's done he's been
through practice and done what he's been
able to do there the thing I would I
think will be interesting is how does
Josh Rosen assuming and I'm assuming
that this is probably going to be his
last game if he does play it at UCLA you
know does he want to go out on a high
note where he can lead a team to a to a
winning record and would that be the
last thing or is just hey you know get
ready for the NFL Draft and move on I
mean physical talented is phenomenal
with with him it's just you know and I
don't think anyone's gonna make a
determination whether it plays in it or
not you know write him off because his
talent is so good and by the way you're
seeing more and more kids do what for
Annette and Christian McCaffrey did I
think it's only going to keep happening
where a kid may be nicked up although
he's gonna go you know what I'm not
playing you know it's just they're
they're seeing that guys if you're good
enough the NFL is still gonna draft you
and take your chances and people going
well it's not a playoff game and I think
that's where some some people are making
the determination is it a playoff game
Royce Freeman really good running back
at Oregon he was with this team but he
didn't do anything in the bowl and I'm
not sure you know how you know until NFL
team say you know we're gonna question
your your competitiveness and all that
other stuff if you don't play with your
teammates for this last time I don't
think it's gonna slow it down at all I
just think you're gonna see more and
more well for net McCaffrey wound up
being top 10 picks and we're seeing how
well they've been playing in their
rookie season all you got to do is take
a look at Jake but how his rookie season
went finished on IR never got off IR
because of his knee going down against
Florida State in that bowl game man and
I don't blame these woods for really
good running Cowboys have a really
linebacker who was a great player oder
Dame his bladder does not go well I know
he said it didn't regret it but you
wonder where he got drafted well I mean
as you know you know Jerry Jones took
took Smith
he took him in the top of the second
round so no question I hear you before I
let you go we've been in the last hour
we had Brockman and I started going to
head to head where we chose the names of
two quarterbacks in the NFL out of a hat
and asking each other who's stock would
we take I'm gonna give you one right now
Bruce Feldman okay play the music for
him right here Mike tell 2fo whose stock
would you take rosin orde Arnold
Bruce Feldman whose stock would you take
Donald or Baker Mayfield oh I'm gonna
take Baker I'm gonna be honest Baker
yeah just everybody believes that he's
not Johnny Manziel he loves football
he's ultra competitive he's accurate I'm
not betting against Baker you and me
both oh I wouldn't have said that three
months ago but I'm a believer Bruce
happy happy New Year to you and yours
okay brother well you too thanks for a
nice family
you got it Bruce Feldman is calling the
foster farms Bowl Arizona versus Purdue
two days after Christmas all right
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience